but I try to make sure everyone's doing
right now is be more productive than
they've ever been and they need to
prepare for the new world because the
old world as it existed will never exist
but that's not necessarily a bad thing I
think it's a good a lot of people are
gonna realize how easy it is to do
things from the house and also if your
business model is dependent on being
around a lot of people you know that's
not gonna really get you know then tell
you guys people won't be coming outside
whether they can and cannot normally you
know for a couple of years you know a
name so if you notice a lot of
businesses like you know Macy's closed a
lot of doors and AMC went out of
business and women Marcus went out of
business
think about how many oh sorry we didn't
go out of business and bars and closed
you know like you know like at least for
now and if like once this is over it's
still gonna take a while for people to
come outside so it doesn't mean it's
gonna be no way to make money it means
you got to figure out how to make money
because my work depends on people hiring
me well that's a good thing that you
have you know family companies but you
know right now what I would do is be
modeling my own products and selling a
direct-to-consumer you know leveraging
the fact that you've already modeled but
you can make products you come from good
lineage no I'm saying you have good
people around you a good creative crew
and I will start doing movies I will
start doing television shows undergrads
arguing and you know III would do
scripted stuff stuff I always say we're
all in an unprecedented time right now
and I'm actually very lucky though to be
working in the food industry and so as a
food blogger a lot of people are turning
to food for comfort or you know all the
reasons so for me I've had record number
of pageviews record number of profile
visits record number of people like
remaking my recipes yeah
my struggle right now is how do I get
brands to actually want to do sponsored
work because all of a sudden March 10th
March 11 like just came screeching to a
halt like nobody wants to do that
anymore
you don't food companies are tightening
up you know you know yesterday one of
our clients emailed us and said we're
not paying you this is seven figures and
you're getting fired and we might be
going back groped you don't get that you
don't get to affect the other side what
you do right now is a hopefully you've
either saved or you're humble enough to
go backwards this is for everybody be
you go ham on producing as much content
doing as many lives going across every
platform even trying to even waiting to
do tick-tock you've been waiting to do
Twitter you do all that now you build up
so in 180 days when she's truly back to
normal you're getting that this is chess
right now not checkers it's not direct
it's macro so go ham like all in like so
many people are dwelling I've heard from
a thousand of you already yeah like Gary
I'm crushing but all my money's gone
because the brands aren't sponsoring I'm
like uh-huh I'm like remember when I
told you if there was a recession like
influencers wouldn't be as fun anymore
yes good news this a fake recession aka
it doesn't have the underlining
principles to be something super long
it's likely we'll get back to normal
somewhere here later I mean the biggest
the biggest elephant in the room is if
this reopened winter like some experts
are saying then you're starting to get
into some but but if not then you know
we're gonna be back to normal somewhere
in the next 90 120 160 180 days I think
you need to build build build big bill
and then take the opportunities when
they come that's what I say to young
people today look at this pandemic this
corona virus pandemic you know it's
really tragic because it attacks the old
guys mmm
but this but even worse is the baby
boomers had it the easiest of all
generations but now that their pensions
are gone their 401ks are gone yep Social
Security's broke Medicare's broke
so I say to younger people this pandemic
this crisis it's the best thing that
ever happened to you you know you think
about that iPhone you have more power in
that iPhone that I had with my Sperry
UNIVAC mainframe computer and then so
when I meet people as all the economy is
bad I said this the only economy is
between this here and that here mmm no
there's an economy out here but this is
the best time for your generation
because your tech savvy
I'm not tech savvy no you got this was
made for you guys the old pious like may
have been cleaned out by the pandemic
bring your cash way is clear for you now
the old guys are gone they're dead yeah
so it's really a great time but exactly
as you're talking about the bad times
are the link of the best times that's it
yeah yep you can see it but some
unfortunately as you knows a lot of your
generation are younger
they'll never recover yeah there's the
worst of times
hey now and they're gonna they're gonna
reflect back this in five years in ten
years and say that's a thing that
screwed me up or hurt me and and be a
victim to it as opposed to saying okay
this is happening and how can I make the
most of it and what's it gonna take for
me to learn a new skill or get more
creative or be hungrier and this time
are more important who's your teachers
mmm who are we listening to well you
know that's why I keep saying to the
Millennials you know if they're PAC
ellipse you know I make Millennials who
are just horrifyingly weak snowflakes I
call them they go to college and norm
adds they've got trigger events you know
the I don't know what they say to that
but they've got to have special rooms
where there's no whatever I'm going
holy mackerel welcome to the real world
you know Millennials who are as tough as
nails I mean this is the biggest
opportunity they've ever had huge so it
just depends upon what's between this
year this year what's in your heart
that's yeah for the what do you think is
the the number the next step the first
step or the number one step for the
average person with you
the kind of the normal job that they
might be losing if they have some dead
they got some credit card what's the
next step for them to not only survive
but thrive in this market in this time
oh I always say quit your job but that's
not I don't have a job I never had one
job and I never wanted a job after that
because I had to be hungry nothing to
say you know but it were all different
we're humans weren't different beings
sure this diagram here yes it's why I
created my cash flow board game mm-hmm
we have four different intelligences
where mental intelligence we have
collagen he probably had very good
physical to making all in all that yeah
emotional intelligence but spiritual
intelligence so I went to military
school in New York the first thing is
spiritual you know I become a Marine
it's spiritual yeah you know I mean
because you're putting your life on the
frickin line yeah you know so Nassim
Taleb you know I wrote the book the
Black Swan you also wrote anti fragile
this is three kinds of people in the
world
there's fragile and that's where our
school systems are putting out fragile
would be snowflakes and that's our
choice you want to be that way
have a good life mm-hmm the second type
is that sauce fragile is like a
champagne flute
yeah you hit the shatters then the
second one is called robust and a robust
person is like the rock you know you can
pound on a dump on oh yeah they take it
but that's all they do they taken and
that anti fragile there's somebody like
you where they pound the crap out of you
and you get smarter and better because
mm-hmm so I love Nassim Taleb you know a
lot of people call it Doctor Doom but
the way I look at this whole thing this
economist publicly I heard oppression
you know we're not gonna get out of this
really oh yeah and so the thing is it's
just good for you or bad for you I'm
looking forward to it you know the last
the last crash was 2008
yeah and I made more money in 2008 that
in my whole life so this one here mm you
know what is a 20/20 I'm gonna get even
richer but I'm gonna get poor and if
they're baby boomers I got employment on
this coronavirus all by health you know
that hey hit the road put on some
running shoes change your diet get some
sunlight yeah get healthy don't go don't
be a wimp but oh I'm so afraid of dying
dad you don't even know it yet so many
people are asking about my perspective
on the coronavirus first of all this
would not be a lot virus that we would
see snow the first is not gonna be the
last then this will last forever in my
last two months three months five months
eight months ten months a year we don't
know no one knows just like as you know
I was born in Hong Kong and back then
sauce affected Hong Kong's tremendously
tremendously so I definitely did this
affects
our lives affects my family's life even
my relatives in Hong Kong no doubt
but knowing that was not gonna last
forever things would bounce back to
normal it's just a matter of time
unfortunately I could also see as the
business land there are few companies
benefiting from this tragedy
tremendously there are few companies
right now making insane profits that a
lot of the fear even brings spread on
social media there are purely money
driven just like it always is just like
it always is has money driven so as an
individual as I've said many many times
in my other previous videos that is very
critical to have a way that you could
make a living from home they could work
remotely we've got now a lot of people
are staying home that they cannot go out
and they're getting they're getting
hours cut then they may not be able to
go to work and we don't know again how
long this will last but having that
skill that you can work remotely and
most of my students work remotely most
of my team members
having a skills I saw hope this is a
sometimes a warning a reminder how
important that is not just relying on
one job instead developing a skill set
you could
catalog excuse that you could rely on be
optimistic
hold the line the line is we're gonna
get through this we get through it to
the other side we're gonna be better
yeah is that true so if any of your
going through the uncertainty and the
doubt and the not sureness and then to
depression and then pop them back to
optimism for a second trust me
everybody's doing the same thing I would
expect it unless you got some kind of
psychological issue you are probably
just like me going back and forth
between when do we get out or we're
going to get out what's it gonna look
like on the other side how can I get
back to work stir crazy mania love to
know what you're going through how
you're getting through this today this
is what I'm gonna do today this is what
you might try today find three things
you can do three things you can get done
okay three customers that you haven't
done business with in a while three
people just to this in threes three
things you can do to take care of
yourself three things you can do to take
care of somebody else right things you
can
to create the future you wanted a to put
it in place to firm it to move it
forward so that
June October December you have something
to look forward to
something in front of you something to
pull you forward put something on that
calendar out in front of you hey I'm
coming back we're coming back and I'm
gonna be ready when we get back if you
want more advice wisdom guidance from
other successful entrepreneurs on how
you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me I hope you find it
valuable continue to believe and I'll
see you there the ventilator can't
necessarily move the oxygen around